masai et les forces de l'ordre
commencent à quitter la place de la
république les choses sont rentrées dans
l'ordre et absolument vous voyez
lesquels montrent gendarmerie qui sont
en train de quitter la place de la
république il ya plus de manifestants
ils ont tous été dispersés ça a pris un
certain temps parce qu'il a fallu
d'abord nas et ces manifestions c'est en
tout cas la stratégie qui a été choisi
par les forces de l'ordre qui ont laissé
donc les derniers manifestants sortir au
compte gouttes en étant parfois à
fouiller parfois contrôlé par les forces
de l'ordre
l'idée c'était évidemment d'éviter
qu'une nouvelle manifestation sauvage ne
se forment à proximité de cette place de
la république voilà donc qui met un
terme à cet après-midi de manifestations
manifestation d'abord calme d'abord
pacifique avec plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui se sont rassemblées dans
les rues de la capitale
et puis les choses
et dans l'après-midi lorsque certains un
groupe de manifestants s'en sont pris
aux forces de l'ordre mais assez des
barricades parfois incendié aussi des
barricades et ça a donc provoqué 2
face à face des face à face très tendu
entre
des manifestants et des forces de
l'ordre notamment sur cette place de la
république lorsque les premiers
manifestants sont arrivés on a assisté à
des scènes assez impressionnante avec
les images de nicolas coupé où vous avez
pu voir et bien des manifestants d'abord
arraché une partie de la palissade qui
avaient été dressées palissade anti
émeute qui a été dressé par les forces
de l'ordre et puis jeté un grand nombre
de projectiles vers ses forces de
l'ordre qui ont tenté de disperser la
foule avec du gaz lacrymogène avec
beaucoup de grenades de désencerclement
et à ce propos on a eu pas mal de
retours de la part des strips medic des
secouristes qui opère pendant ces
manifestations sur le fait qu'il y avait
un certain nombre de blessés notamment à
cause de ses éclats a provoqué par
l'explosion des grenades de
désencerclement une après-midi tendu la
présence des casseurs a d'ailleurs été
critiquée par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin qui a dit que les
casseurs casser la république ce sont
ses termes voilà donc pour cet après
midi une manifestation contre la loi
sécurité globale l'article 24 mais aussi
l'article 21
22 et plus globalement contre la
précarité dans le pays ces précisions
comme abonnés en direct de la place de
la république où la manifestation est à
présent terminée